this family clearly find comfort in
being in this city this is the exact
spot in Nottingham where their 19 year
old son Barnaby Weber lost his life
as police held traffic back they laid
flowers on the road where he died
31 year old valdo calacani of no fixed
address is charged with the murders of
Barnaby fellow student Grace O'Malley
Kumar and school caretaker Ian Coates
they were stabbed to death on Tuesday
also studied in this city he left the
University of Nottingham last summer
after graduating from a course in
mechanical engineering he's due to
appear before magistrates on Saturday
kalikarni's family vicar in West Wales
said his thoughts were with the victims
when I saw the photographs of the
victims in the in the press it just it
was overwhelming to think that lives
have just been cut down like that so
horrifically and so our hearts went out
to the victims and we were praying for
them the three victims who all loved
sport were remembered on day one of the
ashes the biggest day in cricket started
with a moment of silence
and to commemorate Barnaby and Grace
both talented cricketers during the 56th
over the number on Barnaby's Cricket
shirt Amazing Grace was played from the
stands
[Music]
look at the biggest context of things
outside of ashes and playing crickets
the purpose of sport is to bring people
together and harmonize communities
and today is no different in
Nottingham's Market Square the mass of
flowers just grows
innocent people I just think it's so
cruel and so harsh I don't even know
what to say
[Music]
should come also be part of the
community morning also on people's minds
here are the three others who were run
over during these attacks two are in a
stable condition and one has been
discharged from hospital kalakani is
also charged with their attempted
murders
this week has ended three lives and
changed countless others here it is the
week this city will never forget
Lisa Dowd Sky News Nottingham